tonight I am speaking to you because
there is a growing humanitarian and
security crisis at our southern border
why should Congress cough up the money
to build a border wall one of trumps
claims is that it would help stop the
flow of deadly drugs coming in from
Mexico this is a humanitarian crisis a
crisis of the heart and a crisis of the
soul in fact marijuana has always been
the most smuggled drug from Mexico by a
longshot but over the last few years
even shipments of weed have declined by
more than 75% and this trend has nothing
to do with increased border security or
a crackdown on the Sinaloa cartel and
its former leader Joaquin el chapo
guzman who was sentenced to life in
prison in u.s. federal court last week
the fall-off in pot smuggling is a
direct result of legalization I sat down
with David bier a policy analyst at the
Cato Institute who wrote the cover story
of our April issue about how easing pot
prohibition is doing what the failed war
on drugs never could well marijuana
legalization in the United States which
really started with Colorado in
Washington and 2014 has really shifted
the supply of drugs from Mexico to state
legal growers in the United States and
that shift has reduced marijuana
smuggling dramatically along the border
in 2018 the vast majority of drugs by
value came into the country through
ports of entry not way out in the
wilderness somewhere and if you look at
it as a result of the legalization of
marijuana the overall value of drugs
crossing between those ports of entry
has declined by 70%
so the president is not only focusing on
a small share of the border drug trade
it's focused on a shrinking share of
that drug trade what a border wall have
any effect on stopping the flow of drugs
into the country well the best evidence
we have for that is between 2003 and
2009 the border patrol built over 500
miles of fencing along the border and
that had no effect whatsoever on the
drug traffic coming into the United
States and it
to be measured both by the use rates in
the United States or by the rate at
which were seizing the drugs not only
did they build these fences but they
launched a drone fleet they doubled
their workforce it had no effect and in
2013 the Drug Enforcement Administration
issued a report on drug smuggling and
they basically threw up their hands and
said we just need a lot more resources
to get a handle on drug smuggling
between ports of entry and then in five
short years almost you know 78 percent
of that drug trade between those ports
of entry for marijuana has declined and
yet we just had the longest government
shutdown in American history over the
question of whether to build a wall and
drugs were regularly raised as
justification for building that wall do
you think that there's a failure of
emphasis that the emphasis should be at
ports of entry or is there an overall
decline even across you know the entire
border at the end of the day I don't
think that the drug war at the border is
any more effective than the drug war
inside of the United States has been it
hasn't reduced demand for drugs it's
created huge problems both with our
relationship with Mexico and other
Central American and the Latin American
countries and so I don't advise him to
say we should just double down on the
drug war at ports of entry but if his
goal is to seize as many drugs as
possible have added at ports of entry
because between ports of entry taking
people's private property to build a
border wall I mean it's not even related
to drug trafficking it's so you know it
distant from the phenomenon so at this
point I would advise the president to
move on look at marijuana legalization
look at how effective that is apply some
lessons to other drugs don't double down
on the border security drug war what
about the cartels how are they
responding to legalization
well they've trying to shift to other
drugs and traffic methamphetamine and
and cocaine and heroin and fentanyl and
try to make up the difference so far it
doesn't look like it's been successful
the decline in mera
smuggling it's been so dramatic that the
total value of drugs appears to have
also declined even counting the stuff
that comes in through ports of entry so
it doesn't look like their strategy has
worked and so much so that they've
actually shifted to starting to use
these drug tunnels to smuggle humans
bring in people who want to pay a lot to
come through the express lane into the
United States and so that's a sign that
really the the drug traffic that's
coming in between ports of entry is
declined by so much that they're looking
for other ways to get value out of their
investment other than that you said the
tunnels are they're kind of more
complicated ways that marijuana
legalization is interacting with illegal
immigration I think these phenomenon are
very distinct you know the president
treats illegal immigration is largely a
phenomenon of drug smugglers coming into
the United States that's not the reality
only a very very tiny fraction of people
who are coming in are drug smugglers and
that's according to the Border Patrol's
own statistics on this issue if you look
at just the gang members that they've
arrested on the board or just constitute
less than half a percent of all of their
apprehensions so the vast majority of
people crossing the border into the
United States are not drug traffickers
they're families trying to reunite with
family in the United States they're
workers trying to fulfill labor demand
north of the border the biggest kind of
Bugaboo in this question right now is El
Chapo right you hear this name a lot
Trump invokes him as a kind of an avatar
of all that is evil about having borders
open or letting people move back and
forth across the border I've heard the
argument made that we have essentially
created people like that with the drug
war and with the immigration reduction
do you think that's true it is
absolutely the case that we have
empowered cartels along the border both
through the drug war and immigration
enforcement by narrowing the options for
legal entry you really empower cartels
who are trying to control the trade if
there's only a few entry points that
they can control then that really gives
them the Opera
to monopolize and drug wars gang wars in
Mexico are driven by the demand and
desire of those drug gangs to control
those ports of entry those those limited
areas along the border where people can
get in if Goods and people flow freely
the the control of the cartels goes down
dramatically they aren't able to charge
smuggling fees they aren't able to
control the ports of entry and you won't
have the problems that we see and the
control that we see by the drug cartels
right now would you say that the cartels
respond to supply and demand in the
American market and how easy it is to
bring it in whatever the market demands
the cartels will try to fulfill and if
you look at it from the mexican growers
perspective if the demand for marijuana
goes down it really forces them into
position of deciding is it valuable
enough to continue to grow it and
there's some very interesting anecdotes
about farmers in Mexico who are saying
just that you know in 2014 as
legalization is crashing the Mexican
marijuana market the you know they're
debating whether they can even continue
to grow marijuana what's happened to
black markets for drugs in states that
have legalized well we have a spectrum
Colorado has probably had the most
successful model for marijuana
legalization according to their
government they've essentially
eliminated the entire black market in
Colorado all that's now you know
homegrown marijuana California has been
a lot less successful in part because of
the regulations and taxes licensing laws
in particular have been an obstacle to
getting legal marijuana to replace the
illicit forms and Washington somewhere
in the middle Nevada somewhere in the
middle Alaska again would fall somewhere
in the middle where they've had a lot of
success but not full success as a result
of some of the
and licensing requirements that impede
full penetration of the illicit market
are there lessons for people who want to
reduce or end the pathologies around
illegal immigration from the process
that we've just gone through the
political process of legalizing
marijuana
oh absolutely if you look at what
happened with marijuana legalization it
reduced the demand for illicit marijuana
and that's the exact same thing that we
want to do in the illegal immigration
space if you make it easier for people
to immigrate legally that reduces the
demand to get smuggled across the border
or to enter illegally and that's exactly
what we do not have in the u.s.
immigration system right now which is a
legal pathway for people without a
college degree to come to the United
States and work year-round in industries
where their labor is being demanded and
if we had that process for people to
come legally you wouldn't see the
illegal immigration that we have now the
people who are being apprehended by
Border Patrol between ports of entry
right now are overwhelmingly according
to Border Patrol coming to reunite with
family coming to work in the United
States coming for peaceful purposes
[Music]